this is the sound of a new generation of
ukrainians unbowed by war resurrecting
what's been lost
each weekend hundreds of young
volunteers from across ukraine and as
far away as london donate their own
money raise more through crowdfunding
and hire coaches to carry them two hours
north from kiev to get here
then they go to work
they call it a cleanup rave we cannot
all be on the front line
shooting
and struggling for our country but we
can do something useful here staying at
our homes at our country
so someone destroys our country and
someone's someone needs to rebuild
russian rocket strikes turned the house
from this
into this
with no hope of saving it the workers
clear the way for reconstruction there's
a spirit in the people that i can't find
anywhere else and
yeah it's it's
it's really touching on march 5th this
man his pregnant wife and his brother
were in the basement when rockets struck
somehow everyone survived
so many people have come together i'm
very grateful for that we'll try to
adopt rebuild and move forward to
victory
through pouring rain searing heat and
summer sun they work until the site is
cleared
these volunteers came here to listen to
some music have a good time and rebuild
their country brick by brick
when it's done anton pojak's
father-in-law who owns the home says
thank you
[Music]
the reward a free concert from ukrainian
electro folk band onuka whose singer
says she takes inspiration from the
youth of ukraine and its defiance in the
face of an ongoing war
i do feel it in their
eyes and i think that if we have such
powerful young generation so
impressive so
encouraged
i have no hesitation that ukraine won't
stand with this
then
they party as only their generation can
celebrating in a torrential downpour in
a cultural center gutted by shelling in
the region where the ukrainian army
drove out russian forces
john hendren al jazeera ivanivka
northern ukraine